I have a really inspiring story you do a
lot of people you know may like to need
to hear like to hear you know so
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally L.A
what was your family like
you said what was your family like my
family I was in foster care since I was
two years old oh really yeah I bounced
around foster care I got adopted at 11
by a foster parent but
um situations happens where I just end
up leaving her too what was going on
with your biological parents
um I honestly don't know I was taken
away when I was two years old I was told
plenty of different stories but
I'm not sure exactly what so
how would you describe your childhood in
general
oh pretty long I had a long life with
like the whole 23 years of my life I've
been here I went through something
traumatic probably at least every year
really yeah for example
um foster care you know bouncing around
um
one of the busy biggest thing is being
molested multiple times by
family members and
um Foster system is really screwed up
isn't it yeah they don't really you know
check on the kids and stuff like that
like how they're supposed to
and then um when I finally got away from
the people who are molesting me
um at nine years old I came too long I
went to Long Beach California and
um that's what I was adopted at but
um even her dude that she were that she
was with he tried to touch me and that's
when I tried to leave there and I
reached out to the foster care system
to you know get them to help me out and
stuff like that they told me I checked
out too early that they couldn't help me
and I even explained that you know I was
being mistreated and
um
was
about to be touched
um and
they still said they couldn't help me
so yeah that system is bad
foster care how far are you in school
um I actually
I'm not you know I'm sadly I only have
14 credits left I have 14 credits left
in high school before I just basically
dropped out
because of the life that I had to live
after that but when did you start
working as a prostitute
18.
18 years old respectable age
you said respectably it's a respectful
it's not 13 or 14 like some of the girls
yeah I heard a lot of
teen 14 year old girls a lot of times
they you know it comes from either what
I've been through being touched so it
made them being curious and then you
know was misled because you know
I one thing that I can say though when I
started prostituting I started off as a
renegade like you know I didn't start
off with a pimp I really only had one
real pimp since I've been doing this
since 18 to now
and one thing that I can say though I'm
very observant and guys can be really
really persuasive especially when it
comes to being in this game because it's
hard to kind of be in this game without
a pimp or a protection or you know a guy
there but also besides that just of the
game just grows how they feel being out
here you know especially going through
things that I went through you know
being molested and touched young makes
you like
feel like you need a guy to fill a hole
and so that's when it is very easy to
get persuaded as a woman especially that
young to an outsider watching these
videos perhaps
you hear you hear these stories about
girls like yourself who are
with temps and you're like um why why
would you do that keep the money for
yourself but I've seen girls who
honestly
I wouldn't
I never had to say that it was like I I
never been the type of person to say
that there's a certain way that female
should do this like I said I started off
as a renegade but that was because of
what I've been through you know like I
said I already been touched on and took
advantage of as a kid so I always about
to myself before that I thought I was
even going to be homeless I vowed to
myself that I would never let nobody
take advantage of me so when I became
homeless and I had to do what I had to
do to put a roof over my head food in my
stomach and you know take care of myself
I did it with myself one I didn't even
have a guy available at the time to even
put that in my head but at the same time
though too
it was just like
that just wasn't my like my thought
process of it like I just always like
okay if I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do
it for myself but at the same time I
don't
um
talk down or look down on the girls that
do have those that are started out with
those because like I said once again
it's easy to feel persuaded and get
persuaded into that situation especially
when you go into it young and you know
going into a young that means you had no
home you know stuff like that but
besides that though too it's easy to
want a man because of the things that
can't go on out here being robbed you
know I've been held at gunpoint multiple
times
guys thought they were going to take my
money or they thought they were going to
touch me because they had a gun to my
head and you know just the type of
person that I am though you're not going
to do that to me like I said but can a
pimp really save the day in that
situation because that's like that's
that's a matter of seconds when that
goes and that's what a lot of people
don't understand there it can be certain
situations where a pimp could save the
day you know but it is a lot of
situations where that Split Second yeah
she won't even be able to get in contact
with her to be able to get him to know
that something is going on what I was
about to say earlier is I've seen girls
whose pimps get arrested and get put in
jail yeah and I'm I'm surprised at how
they just don't they lack the survival
skills
is I don't know if they get lost I had
one fall asleep while I was getting
choked out in a room before it well he
wasn't my PIV it was just a a guy that I
was dating or whatever and
um
I was working at the Cheesecake Factory
the covet started so the job got shut
down and so that's when I had to go back
to doing this or whatever and I was
already dealing with a guy but when I
first started dealing with I was already
I was at a regular job so I wasn't doing
this he didn't even know that I could do
that like I could be on that type of
program you know or whatever but
um when the opportunity presented
himself for him you know basically I
built him
to be a pimp you know he and
one day I'm out you know working
whatever and
he's supposed to be me watching BMI uh
protection and um I get go on a date
with a guy Mexican one hand
and um we go inside the room and we do
everything and then the guy you know
basically didn't get to finish and
as soon as I'm finna walk out the door
the guy chokes me from behind and me and
him is tussily I'm trying to fight to
get out of the choke hold and when I got
out you know he started grabbing me
again just tussling for like at least
like 13. 20 minutes 15 20 minutes
I only say that to say that I told the
guy that I was with oh I'm gonna come
downstairs
me not coming downstairs within five
minutes you should have been knocking on
that door like what's going on
he didn't come upstairs I'm fighting
with this guy 15 20 minutes I finally
get loose myself I didn't think to oh
look for the hit the car our car that
we're in I'm thinking to run for my
safety so that's just right there
perfect example Split Second where even
if they are out there with you sometimes
the safety doesn't matter yeah but what
I'm saying is I've seen girls whose
pimps get put away put away
and you would think they use that as an
opportunity to make money on their own
but they don't they run to another pimp
immediately once again that's just
that that just depends on the
mind frame of the girls too because like
I said some females really feel like
they need a guy yeah I think they get
lonely out there and they feel like they
need the protection yeah
tell me about your clients you said the
word your clients your customers
oh
I don't know they're all different kinds
is all different types out here you know
run into all different kinds nice mean
rough
all types what does it taught you about
men huh what is what is this work taught
you about men
you said what have you learned about men
um by doing this work
[__] they'll give you as much as they
want as long as they can get what they
wanted
if they don't get finished they'll for
sure try to give you more but
seriously one thing that I learned about
men
from a pen perspective that a lot of
these guys out here they're just out
here just to make yourself feel better A
lot of them don't even know
what a real pimp is you know to
like even especially here in L.A yeah
like really even call yourself that or
you know but
everybody is following you know the
trend and stuff like that so you know
they're going to do what they do but
men will know how to talk their way into
a lot of situations whether if it's a
pimp or a trick you know because there's
some tricks out here that they've been
out here spending money for with females
for so long that they know how to talk a
female that don't know
they know how to talk about some things
you know or getting a lower price or
whatever so man they they know how to
use their mouth very very good that's
one thing I learned for sure
what's more important You Love or Money
honestly to be honest love love and I
just want to honestly I really don't
want to do this like you know I mean
money yes is good just because you know
you can't do anything without money this
world revolves around money
you know but at the end of the day I
just feel like I
home is where the heart is so
how does this impact your life
emotionally
I'm dealing with mental things as of
right now you know just because
everything that I've been through is
still going through you know so I'm
dealing with my mental as of right now
but I'm a very strong person you know
I've been through a lot of things I got
tatted on my spine God gave it toughest
by the strongest soldiers and I really
believe that so I just keep going
did you have dreams of doing something
else with your life when you're younger
oh or not when I was younger I used to
want to be a judge really yes but as of
now though like I really just want to
get settled you know get stability and I
want to open my own hair business I'm I
do cosmetology I want to go to school
for cosmetology and just open up my own
beauty salon and stuff like that so are
you saving money now
as of right now I'm working on it you
know it's kind of hard to when you stay
in a hotel room so that's what I'm
working on just getting into a better
living situation so that way I can
really save money
um
I don't I had a miscarriage lost a kid
so but I don't have actually living kids
no
keep it that way if you want to I try to
as long as I can I do want a kid but I
want to be stable you know like I said
I've been through foster care I always
tell myself I don't want my kids to go
through anything I've been through right
you think you could desensitize to how
how dangerous and crazy this lifestyle
is you said do you think you could
desensitized to how dangerous and crazy
this lifestyle is
oh well what do you mean by distance
ties you know after like because I
I have people even say like the way I
react to certain situations is way
different like I said I had guys tried
to rob me you know at gunpoint and
my reaction literally looking out and
dead in the eyes like you're gonna have
to kill me if you think you're gonna
rape me like you're not you're not gonna
rape me or know that that's pretty
desensitized so and when I had taught
that to a girl that has been out here
longer than me and she was like you said
what
and I repeat it again she said never she
was like
I don't even think I would have
responded that way
you know so I don't know I just I really
feel I look at myself as a rose that
grew up out the concrete
I've grown for where Roses Don't Go from
I'm a very sweet
pretty thing but
I've been through a lot of hardship so
I'm not gonna go for a lot of [__]
and you think you get addicted to this
fast money
I wouldn't say addicted
because like I said I have stopped this
before just to go to a regular job and
like I said I don't want to do this like
you know
I would like to do anything else but at
the same time I'm not just going to
settle
you know because once again when I
stopped when I did work at the
Cheesecake Factory you know
a lot of people take advantage of being
a boss
And when they see that people are
sometimes having hard times you know
they just make it a little bit harder
so you know
I never been good at listening to people
like so I had no help nobody to listen
to so what's the hardest part of this
life this job for you actually doing the
dates
doing what I got to do for the money
you have regulators
not no more I used to because I stopped
for a while so I lost all of them broke
phones so don't got the same phone no
more just there's plenty of new guys out
there I mean yeah but I don't want to
keep meaning guys I just want to get
myself together and get out
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work
that we are really the strongest woman
there are like we have to really have
tough skin to work out here you know
rather if it's just because
how it looks like we're
treating ourselves as low women because
we are doing
these things to get money but they have
to understand that once again sometimes
these are only the cards that people are
dealt with
you know and
there is so many hard things that
females go through it's been females
that's been killed out there robbed out
there you know is a lot of females
that's taken advantage of mistreated so
we are really like a
the strongest woman they are
like real tough skin
to even
go through something and still get out
there the next day and be like you know
what because I got to do this I gotta I
got to do what I gotta do
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
honestly I wouldn't have done anything
differently because I feel like the life
that I lived
it's meant to be like it made me the
person that I am and how strong I'm
supposed to be I spent times where I
wanted to take myself out but I didn't
succeed it and that's how I knew that
the my purpose on this Earth
was not it hasn't been made yet so and
you're learning from your mistakes yeah
some of them some of the things that I
went through wasn't even my fault you
know
not blaming on anything else but you
know it wasn't in my control that's the
best that's a better way to say it it
wasn't in my control I couldn't control
it because I was a kid but now that I'm
getting older you know I'm learning how
to take control of my life
you've been in love before
have I been in love yeah
yeah
tell me he wasn't a pet no that's good
do you have friends
somewhat yeah
you know Associates
Associates throughout temps I mean are
not friends Associates friends you know
I mean because people say they [__] with
you and then you know but when the hard
times really come like all the most of
the things that I've been through in my
life all the hard times I've been
through my life I've been through by
myself so who cannot really say as a
friend
what advice would you give to a young
lady who's thinking of doing this kind
of thing
whoa whoa really if you you can do
anything else don't do it you you know
like but if you
use the cars you dealt with just
play a smart really stack your money
you know and every day that you do
see that it's going make sure you just
stay down until it's just don't go no
more because
these slow days they're not worth it
and spend like just blowing the money
you're not gonna get nowhere you're just
gonna keep on going in circles and
really being out here even if you have
the mentality of oh you don't want to do
this forever
is easy to fall back down into it
because of the simple fact that you're
just not saving your money simply just
being smart about it
than drugs
you said what drugs do I do drugs yeah
I've done drugs but you know I
I left it alone I used to do ecstasy
pills but I don't know no more I drink
though alcohol and smoke weed
and smoke what do you have to be high or
drunk or something like that to do this
kind of work
um I wouldn't say I would have to be but
it does make it easier because it's
um
is easier for
you not to like
get into a bad mood mind frame or
anything you know
it's got to be tough seeing
all these strangers in a night
and the way you do it oh yeah especially
the things that I've been through that's
why I said if I can do anything else I
would but you know
what's your biggest fear
I don't fear anything but God
I don't even feel dead
like if it's my time to go it's my time
to go
I've been through so much where it's
like what is their love to fear I've
been through a lot that a lot of people
just fear that of happening so
the only thing that's worse than this is
death and I don't fear that
so I don't fear anything
is it is it a self-worth issue that got
you into this and keeps you into it
what do you mean by Southwest I mean
like
most women would probably say you
deserve a better life than to be out in
the street selling their ass I mean of
course a lot of females feel like they
deserve better you know but still I had
a lot of people tell me even me with me
being out here just by the way that I
carry myself you can tell that I know
that I'm worth
I know I'm worth more because I don't
let this game make me as in like with
being naked it's been times where I
didn't walked outside like this at night
time
you know it was when I first started I
wasn't even wearing heels but I was
still getting customers and they would
tell me like you know I like how you
still dress classy you know or cover up
you don't got to be naked like you're
not
following everybody else you know you're
making sure you still have some class to
yourself then a day carrying yourself as
a lady so
do you think prostitution should be
legalized
isn't it
but honestly I just feel like
I mean it's our body like you know some
females are not forced into this that's
the things that they should be cracking
down on the people that are forced into
it the the people that are doing sex
trafficking because yeah okay even they
saying they're trying to get these pimps
is people that's in the government
that's doing sex trafficking that's the
things that they should be cracking down
on if a female is out there and she's
walking and she's doing it obviously she
kind of has like her own mind frame and
she wants to do it to type things so a
female should be just like abortions if
a female want to get rid of a baby she
should be able to do that
not everybody is filled with this Golden
Spoon in their mouth you know every time
like I didn't got arrested they oh you
got a pimp no I don't have a pimp I put
myself out here because
my living situation I was homeless I'd
rather do this than living on the street
though because I went too nicely
sleeping on the streets and on the train
before I started doing this at 18 years
old and it didn't feel good
I don't have nobody else to turn to
though so I turned to this
so it's it should be up to
the female itself
just like how everybody else have a
decision oh they want to go do this for
their life or they want to
because it's like who are they hurting
they're not hurting nobody
you're not killing robbing nobody you
know I mean some females do but some
Nick is brought up too like you know
some tricks brought females too so but
as in like just our mindset our
um
what should I say like that
the
um
like our our plans is not to go out
there and hurt nobody it's just trying
to make some money to live
trying to make our life different from
what it is
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned
in your 23 years
my whole life
[__] honestly just really saving
is really one of the most important
things like saving your money save money
like
yeah very few of the girls that I've
interviewed huh very few of the girls
I've interviewed know how to save money
uh yeah I mean and like I said just to
the depends on the lifestyle though like
you know once again you two like you
said you asked me if I do drugs a lot of
girls out here they do gotta do drugs to
be out here you know so that's another
habit though of spending money just like
I said paying rent for a room every day
you know paying rent for a room you
spend three three thousand dollars
inside the room every month
100 a day not just if it's just a
hundred dollars what if it's more
which a lot of rooms did go up so you're
spending more money inside that room
you're giving that room money for an
apartment
so that's what makes it it does make it
hard to save on top but you still got to
feed yourself what if the girls do got
kids
feel me still got other responsibilities
to take us so it makes it hard to save
money but
at the same time though it just all
depends on
how the girl moved though you know
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you love you lots of
luck out there man I wish uh like any
other girl the best of luck too
thank you